uncertainty is hanging over advica one
of the frontline towns in eastern
ukraine
when we met chaplin olena three weeks
ago she brushed away the prospect of war
now she's worried and feels
uncomfortable being on the streets
some of her neighbors openly hostile to
her
[Music]
they think ukraine is guilty party when
it comes to the shelling they don't
believe russia could act like this my
life is at risk in this kind of society
anything can happen especially now
less than a kilometer away at the front
line soldiers are an alert
recently the shelling has intensified
evidence still fresh of the latest
rocket attack
the front line here hasn't moved ever
since the mint's agreement was signed
with leader sides making territorial
gains or losses but now the recognition
by russia of the two suspected republics
of donetsk and luganza puts into
question when the new lines are going to
be drawn
the agreement set at 420 kilometers
demarcation line
giving the russian-backed separatists
only a third of what they see as their
historical land
now with official support from moscow
they could try again to expand their
control
i think
that
i think it will be a border of
the nest and the enhanced region as they
was at the past
not only this area that already have
but further
and i think that is the reason of
most dangerous situation here basically
we understand that we are on the way of
them
the ukrainian army is in a difficult
situation
many civilians in this area don't
support it they welcome the separatists
back in 2014
and continue to support russia now
others like victor blamed the current
situation under government in kiev
what are they fighting for who are they
fighting for here i don't see any sense
in that if it's for me or my family
there's no need
what are they doing here if you're
shelling the separatists all the time
russia can't leave them on their own if
our president had negotiated with them
then things could have been different
with the minsk agreement now in tatters
ukraine has declared advica and other
towns and villages along the front line
restricted areas but for the soldiers
the most difficult battle could be
winning over the support of the people
hamid al-jazeera advica in eastern
ukraine